[Music]
giordando was one of the biggest names
in british television beamed into homes
around the country as the face of bbc
news and with her co-host nick ross even
helping to solve crimes as the two
presented bbc's crime watch program
people all over the country are joining
together once again to solve some of
britain's most difficult and serious
crimes nightmares do sleep well good
night good night
well her shocking murder remains an
unsolved mystery but this week in an
unrelated case a french court heard
another possible sensational theory that
she'd been killed by a hitman in a case
of mistaken identity in a moment i'll be
joined by her former friend and co-host
nick ross plus former scotland now
detective peter blexley but first let's
remind ourselves of that horrific day
a massive police hunt is underway
tonight in west london for the killer of
jill dando who was murdered earlier
today outside her terraced home in
fulham the news stunned the nation
nobody could understand how and why it
happened in the midst of a media frenzy
the police investigation grappled with
little to no hard evidence
finally a particle of firearm discharge
residue was alleged to be discovered on
the clothing of a local man barry george
this led to his conviction and
sentencing to life imprisonment but
years later in 2008 george was acquitted
and released an innocent man
gildando's killer was never found but
over 20 years on the case remains
unsolved well this week a french court
heard she may have been killed by a hit
man in a case of mistaken identity will
we ever know the truth
well in that dramatic fresh twist this
week documents submitted to a french
call suggested jill may be murdered by
russian mafia hitman indicates a
mistaken identity the hit man possibly
hired to kill another bbc journalist
lawyers argue that the killer may
mistaken jill for lisa brinkworth
pictured here next to jill because of
similarities in their appearance and
occupation and they happened to live in
the same area of west london in fact
jill's doctor was alan farthing who was
uh jill dando's fiance it's an
extraordinary series of coincidences
court papers submitted in the trial of
french fashion tycoon gerald murray
claimed he had recruited a hitman to
murder lisa brinkworth after she went
undercover to expose his agency murray
the former boss of elite model agency is
being investigated over alleged sexual
assault and rape involving at least 11
women well joining me now is jill
dando's former tv co-host and friend
nick ross and former scotland yard
detective and undercover hitman although
obviously he was pretending to be that
at the time peter blexley welcome to
both of you uh nick ross um great to
talk to you uh i imagine every time you
see this kind of headline in the media
it takes you back to that horrific day
when your great friend your great
colleague jill was murdered i remember
it so while i was a newspaper let us at
the time had to cover the story it was a
genuinely horrific and shocking story
and of course remains unsolved when
you've seen the details of what came out
of this french court
does it have any plausibility to you
you know it takes me back to that day
piers but it also takes me back to my
first day as a as a national journalist
for the bbc on the world at one
many many years ago when i took up a
story from the press i was sent out to
do a radio feature for it for the world
at one on radio 4.
and it didn't stand up and when i got
back i said i'm sorry the story isn't
true
and i remember the deputy editor saying
to me
well nick we'll send you on another
story tomorrow i hope that stands up
because otherwise on wednesday we'll
send somebody else
this is the reality piers you've edited
national paper you know the importance
for journalists of getting a story out
never research a story too far until it
falls over
this story today is rubbish it's
complete nonsense it goes on the back of
any number of conspiracy theories that
have been pushed right from the start
the metronome police wasted a year on
silly conspiracy theories i spent
quarter of a century with the working
with the police they constantly went on
onto conspiracy theories when there were
much more simple explanations this time
i mean we had slobodan milosevic the the
the leader of the of the serbs who were
supposed to have killed her we've had
arcane some mysterious uh assassin from
serbia we've had a a warlord i think
we're called we've had a hit man from a
bar i think it was called joe in in uh
in spain i think we've had the whole of
the london underworld turn over the
liverpool underworld we've had theories
it was a pedophile i mean this is just
saloon bar gossip
in this case you have a case going
through the french courts where they're
trying desperately to overturn a statute
of limitations they're looking for
anything they can um i don't think lisa
brinkwood herself thinks this is
remotely true this is something her
lawyers have dredged up it's it's
absolutely not nonsense i'm really sorry
we're giving it this publicity i think
something well listen i i could listen i
have no reason to doubt what you're
saying i don't think we know the truth
about this and there have been so many
theories as you say lisa brinkwood i
think you're right i think she does not
believe this has credence what she did
say though which is very interesting
is that it turns out the bbc were given
a warning based on this threat that
there'd been a conversation over her
that a russian mafia hit man had been
hired by this model agency boss to kill
her lisa brinkworth and the bbc were
told about that but she was never
herself told of the threat her security
was increased but that threat
information was not past her what do you
think of that
nothing absolutely nothing i've had
threats against myself they don't come
from there's no relationship with with
the killing of jill dando the killing of
jill dander and it it isn't as as you
keep saying an unsolved mystery i mean i
think pretty much everything is out
there we know pretty much there
everything there is to know about that
there is no ongoing investigation her
family don't want another investigation
those of us on crime which were really
close and were forensically following
the investigation don't think there's
anything unsolved that now that needs to
be resolved but there is a hunger out
there for a story for a story for a
story there's a hunger out there for
some sort of conspiracy and and that's
what we're feeding that and honestly
it's unfair to jill it's so depressing
she was a you know a wonderful reporter
she was a the most popular television
presenter of her age
she was a
real pathfinder for women in television
and i just think it's it's all rather
depressing this when you say that it's
not unsolved what what do you mean
you believe you know what happened
look
if you read
firstly about the the first court
remember she was
we have somebody who was convicted by a
court
a jury
uh that then then
went to a court of appeal
the three learned judges were absolutely
clear there was they thought the person
convicted was rightly convicted
eight years later
because of piece of evidence that in my
opinion should never be offered in the
first place was withdrawn it went to
another trial now eight years later
witnesses couldn't remember it was a
whole different different experience
altogether this person was was acquitted
now do i think we should open a
reopening inquiry no i don't do i think
we should now follow go back on all the
silly conspiracy theories no i don't
nick ross it's good to talk to you as i
say uh like i said at the start it must
always bring back incredibly raw
emotions for you and i completely
understand why you feel yes
don't don't write them all as raw
emotions because what i'm saying must be
biased because she was like no no i
don't mean that at all you know she was
not i was not romantically inclined with
her
associated with anything else
in fact
what i learned from 23 years on crime
watch
is that you have to be
evidence-based it's evidential
evidential evidential
in in this case as in so many others the
evidence doesn't stack up whereas the
evidence that we had in the first court
and in the court of appeal and indeed
magic which was heard in the in the
subsequent appeal was very very powerful
there were five or six reasons why it
clearly wasn't a conspiracy it wasn't a
hitman very very clear iran colleagues
in at quantico and the fbi went through
they were absolutely clear it wasn't a
hitman this was very much like the the
murder of john lennon the forensic uh
psychologist on the case was very clear
right from the start this was going to
be somewhere somebody who was a
personality disordered person so
i didn't there's any great mystery here
any great mystery that still needs to be
solved i guess the mystery is that
it's you can read between the lines what
you're alluding to but the person you're
alluding to
is a free man uh and did win an appeal
and that's i guess
and was acquitted and honestly if if i'd
been on the jury in that last court case
i would have acquitted him as well yeah
on the evidence that i heard
i'm sorry that doesn't mean that the
case should be reopened no but listen
you're absolutely more than most people
entitled to your firm opinion about that
and i have no agenda about this at all
simply it's in all the papers today
based on this french court report and it
is fascinating to get your take on it
and i really appreciate you joining me
tonight thank you nick
thank you
peter mexic well we heard from nick
there he used to run crime watch with
jill down there obviously feel strongly
about this he thinks it's a load of
conspiracy theory nonsense there have
been endless theories it's pretty
obvious who he thinks did this but that
person in the end was
preached and an innocent man
yes and i completely understand mr
ross's frustration and the hurt he must
feel over losing his great friend and
the fact that there is nobody in prison
at the moment
for that crime that of course is
frustrating for many many people i
certainly would like to see the person
who did that crime sentence and and
serving a term of imprisonment but it's
not to be i also was very much taken by
what mr ross said in terms of evidence
evidence evidence well in that we're
like joined at the hip because of course
i'm a former detective so what do you
make of this stuff that's come out of
this french court i mean on the face of
it it's a plausible theory in the sense
that you've got another
top television uh female journalist who
lives in the same area as jill dandel
who had actually her doctor was jill
dando's fiance which is just a
coincidence but she was investigating
this very nasty model agency boss he was
overheard
talking about this mafia hitman he'd
hired to deal with her
that threat apparently was then relayed
back to the bbc but not to her but they
upped her security you put it all
together
and you come forward to now and you
think well
is there any credence to this well
clearly the metropolitan police will be
all over this today because as you say
it's been so widely discussed throughout
the media what should now happen is that
letters of cooperation between the
french authorities and the met should be
exchanged the necessary permissions
granted and that information should be
sent to the met so that it can be tested
to see whether it has any credence
whatsoever
nick i think you're still with us and
you wanted to come back in on that
yeah i mean it's so much for this
reporting is it's just wrong piers and i
don't blame you because you're going
with whatever is is in the papers at the
moment one of the claims to be made is
that uh this uh it was that lisa
brinkworth lived near jill
uh jill's fiance but that's not where
jill was murdered
jill was murdered her own home in gowan
avenue which she very rarely
visited incidentally and she wasn't
followed there which shows why this
wasn't a profession it's one of the many
reasons this wasn't a professional
hit
and now this is all being conflated that
she lived near jill dandov where the
murder took place that's not true right
she she was living with alan father and
her boyfriend at the time
and many of these other things that are
being published at the moment just don't
fit well to be honest nick i think it's
incredibly helpful to have you talk us
through this because no one will know
more about this case than you and you
clearly you know when i talked about the
emotions you have i meant really about
having to go through it all again when
these things blow up like this uh and it
must be just on a human level it must be
painful for you that's what i meant by
that
well yes and you're quite you know
you're right and and for everybody who
was who was associated with her i mean
one of the great things that came out if
anything good can come out of her death
was jill's legacy which is the gildana
incident university college london which
is now the biggest crime science
institute in the world one of the things
you know where peter blexley says we're
joined at the hip on is evidence
evidence evidence it opinions are to a
penny anybody can come up with a theory
it's whether you can actually pin it to
evidence evidence evidence
and in this case for those out there of
your of your viewers who still believe
this was a conspiracy you know i
mentioned there were so many things
against it it wasn't her right home
anybody professional would have known
where she was this person was hanging
around for four hours three or four
hours was seen by four witnesses there
all of whom picked up somebody
very very similar in appearance and one
of whom picked out somebody in an
identity parade
the person used an amateur gun not not a
real gun they had no escape vehicle this
gowan avenue is a straight road after
the murder they had to walk away in full
view of everybody else that's not
professional jill had a key in the door
instead of her pushing her in and and
killing her inside they did it in in
plain view that's not professional they
held the gun firmly against her temple
that's only something you do in a crime
of passion or when you're a real amateur
because you get all the forensic blow
back on you there were so many reasons
this was not a professional hit it's so
clear on the evidence but there is so
much evidence given that you clearly
feel the person who was originally
convicted and then acquitted in the
second
trial is walking free how do you feel
about that
there were times on crimewatch piers
where i really got so upset on the
victim's heart i wanted to take a skewer
and put it in somebody's eyes who who'd
caused them this pain
but i also used to then go to prisons
and meet offenders
and that really
it's a different issue i don't wish
somebody was in prison about this to be
honest i don't think that would reduce
the crime rate one of the things i have
learned paradoxically and through the
gildander institute of crime science and
through working with the police is that
you can't rest your way out of crime and
you can't imprison your way out of crime
in texas they
imprisoned incarcerated infinitely more
people than in denmark but their crime
rates peaked at the same time and went
down at the same time and in pretty much
the same ways
so no i i don't feel so bad that
nobody's in prison over this i just feel
thank god great relief that whoever did
it doesn't appear to have done it again
yeah
nick ross thank you again for joining me
i really do appreciate it and peter
thank you for your expert analysis as
well